[Música]
el 28 de junio de 1963 se publicó en la
ciudad de Buenos Aires en Argentina una
novela experimental que se convertiría
en uno de los grandes referentes
literarios latinoamericanos estamos
hablando de Rayuela de Julio Cortázar
que está cumpliendo 60 años de ser leída
y releída en France 24 queremos
conversar sobre sus ires y beníres con
Margarita Díaz de León ellas doctora en
humanidades con línea en teoría
literaria bienvenida a France 24 antes
de Rayuela Cortázar ya era un autor
publicado con sus relatos breves
bestiario final del juego y las armas
secretas Pero estas obras no le
permitían aspirar a vivir de la
literatura de hecho el autor dijo en
varias ocasiones que no esperaba que
esta fuera su fuente de ingresos Por qué
Rayuela fue un antes y un después en la
pluma de Cortázar
bueno hola qué tal Muchísimas gracias
por la invitación Valentina Buenos días
Buenos días a todo el público
el caso de Cortázar es muy peculiar
porque me parece que él viene de los
cuentos viene de la poesía y va a haber
un cambio importante en la literatura de
Cortázar con su viaje a parís cuando él
se instale en Europa y empieza Pues a
mirar la vida de otra manera totalmente
distinta a preguntarse Por qué pensamos
y por qué sentimos como sentimos Cuál es
el peso del pensamiento Cuál es el peso
de la emoción y me parece que Rayuela
está indagando todas estas cuestiones
existenciales de un Cortázar que ya está
instalado en París y que ha dejado
Buenos Aires y ha dejado también la
influencia del Neo fantástico para
ubicarse más en una filosofía Europea y
en una búsqueda europea como
latinoamericano que le permita explorar
el comportamiento y las emociones
humanas bueno Cortázar se declaraba a sí
mismo como un indisciplinado Rayuela de
hecho fue escrita a ritazos y entre
tiempos de otros trabajos Usted cree que
él en el momento era consciente de estar
creando pues una de sus obras y de las
obras más memorables en general en el
público
yo no creo que ningún escritor esté
consciente de lo que está haciendo En
ese momento de lo que va a suceder no
con la obra o o en la obra misma en
algunas entrevistas por taza el mismo
comentó que nunca pensó que fuera a ser
leído por jóvenes que esa fue su gran
sorpresa él dijo Bueno yo había escrito
para hombres para personas para mujeres
de mi generación y de repente empezaron
a escribirle muchísimos jóvenes y dijo
para mí Era una sorpresa Entonces me di
cuenta que yo había escrito para otra
generación muy diferente a lo a la a la
que yo tenía concebida en el libro no
esto también habla de de que en ese
contexto los jóvenes pues ya tenían
conocimientos De filosofía
conocimientos de arte porque sin esos
conocimientos no se puede disfrutar la
lectura de Rayuela
Bueno hablemos ahora un poco de la
historia dentro de la historia y
hablemos del personaje de la Maga y de
las teorías a su alrededor porque mucho
se ha hablado de si su origen residió en
una mujer real o fue un producto de la
creación del autor al final Rayuela pues
como muchas obras literarias es en
cierta forma un reflejo de la historia
propia de quien escribe
claro por supuesto yo creo que nos sirve
mucho pensar en estas muñecas matrocas o
en en estas que decimos como cajitas
chinas
yo no creo que la maga sea una mujer
real puede ser muchas mujeres reales es
decir la suma de las mujeres reales de
Julio Cortázar o de las mujeres reales
que que rodearon su vida desde su mamá
su hermana su abuela hasta Pues el
mujeres con las que tuvo algún tipo de
relación en ese contexto o la tenía la
maga dentro del libro es una metáfora la
maga está hecha de lenguaje y la maga
está ahí en el libro para ser espejo de
Horacio de Horacio oliveira el
protagonista de Rayuela que es ese
espejo que refleja lo que Horacio no
puede sentir lo que Horacio no puede
vivir y que la maga sí lo esté sintiendo
Y sí lo está viviendo y Horacio lo
quiere alcanzar y no lo puede alcanzar
es como
detrás de una de una imagen de lo que
uno quisiera hacer o de cómo uno
quisiera vivir y no puede Y esa es la
desesperación precisamente del
protagonista y toda la angustia
existencial Que él tiene ahí la mujer es
una la maga es una mujer libre es es una
mujer que siente la vida Todo el tiempo
es la imagen de la vitalidad del
vitalismo y sobre todo de un amor a la
vida maravilloso pero no en un sentido
de la voluntad sino en un sentido de
sentir la vida en el mismo cuerpo no sin
tener que pensarlo tanto como en el caso
de Horacio Oliver Bueno a este a esta
obra esta pieza le llaman la anti novela
o como el mismo le decía la contra
novela y también no vela experimental
Por qué se ganó estos títulos
por su estructura es una estructura que
nos parece novedosa en el contexto mismo
de la obra tiene un tablero de dirección
va saltando no de un capítulo a otro sin
una secuencia lineal va introduciendo
dos ciudades París va introduciendo
Buenos Aires pero de una manera muy
distinta porque el con París hace toda
una especie de geografía de amigos del
Club de la serpiente una geografía
citadina también en el sentido de su
relación con la maga los lugares que
visitaban etcétera En cambio en París en
en Buenos Aires En comparación con París
Ese es una ciudad que maltrata a los
personajes es una ciudad donde está el
manicomio donde está el circo y va
saltando de ciudad en ciudad y va
saltando de capítulo en capítulo y en
los en otros capítulos que la tercera
parte de la novela Aparentemente donde
hay un viejo escritor que a está
escribiendo la novela que probablemente
escriba Horacio de su Estancia en París
Entonces es un es un juego experimental
como muy bien lo dices Valentín en el
sentido en el que El lector tiene que ir
construyendo la novela junto con el
escritor ese es un lector cómplice ese
es un lector Que obviamente va pensando
con la novela que Cómo construir esa
novela y cómo leerla entonces Cortázar
baba va a revolucionar la literatura
latinoamericana y me atrevo a decir que
no solo latinoamericana en hace 60 años
pues Margarita usted muchas gracias por
su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en France 24
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación un
gusto estar con ustedes y festejemos a
Rayuela y le vamos a cortarse Claro que
sí Bueno y a ustedes también Muchas
gracias por su sintonía nosotros vamos a
hacer una breve pausa aquí en directo
América ya regresamos
[Música]